on this saturday night a salute
to prince philip the future king
mourns his father my dear papa was a
was a very special person so much so the
duke
dictated his own funeral plans the icu
crisis
during the pandemic with cases rising
ontario has about 2 300 isu beds
and practice though we have far fewer
because we simply cannot staff them
banking on mark carney the liberals new
star
player plus the rise and fall of matt
gates
now under investigation for alleged sex
trafficking
[Music]
global national with robin gill
today guns bring out across the united
kingdom and throughout parts of the
commonwealth
in honor of prince philip good evening
and thank you for joining us
buckingham palace has complied with
prince philip's wishes
for a low key funeral it will take place
next saturday april 17th on the grounds
of windsor castle
it'll still be steeped in royal
tradition but only a few will attend
the queen his wife have 73 years and a
small group of mourners
today prince charles the future king of
england spoke publicly about his
father's
passing here's our europe bureau chief
crystal gamansing
a wave of mourners descending upon
windsor castle
some grew up with the duke of edinburgh
and regard him as a national figure
regardless of age the loss is understood
did she ask to come yes yeah i wanted to
show
princeton my respect my
my dear papa was a a very special person
who
i think above all else would have been
amazed by the reaction
and the touching things that have been
said about it
a small funeral service attended by the
queen and members of the royal family
will be held at st
george's chapel on april 17th
a specially built land rover which
prince philip had a hand in designing
will carry his coffin to the chapel his
death while not unexpected given his
advanced age
still shook people when news broke
friday shamris clark
was drawn to the castle she stood there
for a long time
quietly watching i don't know what to
say because it's very very sad day for
everyone
i just want to be here because it is a
big thing
while the world has lost a veteran of
the second world war a champion of the
environment
and supporter of young people the queen
has lost her partner of
73 years
their youngest son prince edward and his
wife sophie visited her majesty saturday
morning
as you can imagine my family and i
missed my father enormously he was a
much
loved and appreciated figure
crystal what do we know about who will
be attending next week's funeral service
well we do know that prince harry will
be attending the service for his
grandfather
next week of course that is a huge issue
because
so much has been made about the
fractures in the royal family
prince harry and megan of course
stepping away from active
royal life and moving to the united
states then that bombshell
interview with oprah with allegations of
racism so he
will be in attendance we are also
hearing that british prime minister
boris johnson
will not be attending the service and of
course members of the public they will
not have
any sort of access however it will be
televised
it's such a complicated time in the
world how are coven 19 restrictions
changing what would normally be a very
public affair
yeah that's a really important part of
all of this we are still under some
restrictions by monday they will be
eased but
gatherings are limited only 30 people
that is really why we're seeing
officials such as boris johnson
not attending just to keep it small to
keep it within
that 30 people limit under the
restrictions
and also at the service inside st
george's chapel
all of those in attendance will have to
be wearing masks
crystal goman sing outside windsor
castle tonight thanks crystal
turning now to the pandemic those covet
19 variants of concern are causing chaos
right across canada in the last two
weeks those cases that are confirmed to
be the variance of concern
almost quadrupled to nearly 25 thousand
in ontario health officials say icu
capacity is being stretched to its limit
and as catherine ward explains doctors
and nurses say their biggest battle
right now
isn't the virus it is an atmosphere of
stress stress is in the air
and i see you burger umakba says when
she goes into work it is a guessing game
about how many people
will be there we never know how many
nurses
or even respiratory therapists or even
clerks who are going to be having on any
given shift
in ontario icus continue to fill up on
friday
critical care services ontario reported
out of the 1846
icu patients 572 were covet 19 related
illnesses
77 had been admitted within a 24-hour
period
ontario has about 2 300 icu beds in
practice though we have far fewer
because we simply cannot staff them
nurses may be sick they may have family
members or children who are sick and
when that happens they can't come to
work for two weeks
the province took new measures to
address the staffing challenge
implementing emergency orders to allow
for the redeployment of health care
workers to hospitals
but it's not necessarily a
straightforward process to bring in
people to work in an icu
experts say it's a job that requires
additional training and specialized
skills
it's hard on people to parachute people
into units
we want there to be it on a volunteer
basis to start with at the same time we
have to
accept that they need training and
support in in the units that they're
going into
that learning curve is very steep and
again these nurses that are
that are specially trained are being
stretched thin as in burgett says
getting additional support will help
but the stress is still there of course
any help right now is help
but again we're putting band-aids on
problems that are
duplicating by the minute
catherine ward global news toronto
parts of northwestern new brunswick
which includes the edmondson area are
heading into lockdown
as of midnight residents must stay
within their single household bubble
unnecessary travel in and out of the
region isn't allowed
and schools will revert to online
learning only the province's public
health
officer has confirmed the presence of
the more contagious variants of kova 19
and there may have been community
transmission the men's world curling
championship which began on thursday in
calgary has been suspended because of
covet 19 cases
canada was eliminated on friday after
losing to scotland
shortly after the game the world curling
federation announced some players of
teams that didn't qualify for the
playoffs
tested positive for covet 19. but they
didn't have symptoms
not taking any chances the playoff teams
are being tested
curling canada says it is looking at
rescheduling options but only if the
athletes and officials can be kept safe
under current protocols teams are
confined to the arena
and their hotel we have dueling
political conventions this weekend both
the federal liberals and the federal new
democrats are meeting
virtually of course they've been
debating policy and strategy
ahead of an election our chief political
correspondent david aiken has been
keeping an eye on both david let's focus
on the liberals what stood out for you
well there was lots of talk about
election readiness and fundraising but
there was also some hints about what
might be in the budget on april the 19th
finance minister christian freeland
kicked off the convention by signaling
promised action on child care on
saturday the liberal grassroots voted
for
universal basic income national
pharmacare and
more money for seniors though none of
those votes are binding on justin
trudeau's government
but some of trudeau's ministers did drop
some hints about their budget priorities
such as
helping the aviation sector that could
mean aid for
airlines like westjet and air canada
trudeau himself was
mum on the budget instead he used his
convention speech
to take a shot at his conservative rival
the problem for aaron o'toole
is that he's not interested in real
solutions
to real problems trudeau also has a new
and potentially significant partisan
ally
former bank of canada governor mark
carney who had his political coming out
at the convention on friday night i'll
do whatever i can to support the liberal
party
in our efforts to build a better future
for canadians
carney stopped short of saying he would
run for the liberals
while conservatives and new democrats
poured water on kearney's coming out
basically branding him as an
out-of-touch elite who was a favorite of
the billionaires
the irony for the conservatives it was
stephen harper who appointed
mark carney to be governor of the bank
of canada and harper and carney worked
in lockstep
to get canada through its last economic
crisis
back in 2009 robin david aiken in ottawa
thanks david
greetings friends today new democrats
reconvened for day two of that party's
three-day national convention
it will feature a keynote speech from
ndp leader
chuck mead singh tomorrow the budget is
just over a week away and it'll be the
first real look at the state of our
economy in two years
errata bureau chief mercedes stevenson
spoke with former prime minister
jean-christian about his experience
balancing budgets
what advice he has for justin trudeau's
government here's his diplomatic answer
public life is difficult and all the
premiers and the prime minister are
doing their best
i would disagree with some of the things
they do but i'm not there and i don't
want to be the monday morning
quarterback
what are some of the things you would
disagree with
if they ask me i will tell them but not
through tv
[Laughter]
and you can see the full interview with
clayton tomorrow on the west block with
mercedes-stevenson right here on global
now to a global news exclusive a b.c man
charged with second-degree murder and
attempted murder in a high-profile
homicide
has been acquitted a b.c supreme court
justice ruled
investigators with the province's
special homicide unit
disregarded canadian law when dealing
with key pieces of evidence
as jordan armstrong reports now there
are questions about whether
other criminal cases will get their day
in court
salmon deep gill is a free man after
almost three years behind bars awaiting
trial
the accused has been acquitted on
charges of second-degree murder and
attempted murder
i can say without exaggeration i have
never
seen anything like this before back in
april 2011 just hours after they were
married
manbier casla and his wife were involved
in a fender bender in surrey bc
when kasla got out of the vehicle and
approached the other car
he was shot by a suspect who then left
the scene
gill was charged in 2018 but the murder
case
crumbled after key crown evidence was
thrown out last month
alleged audio of the shooting captured
on a cell phone
seized by the rcmp's integrated homicide
investigation team
or ihit from gill's home deemed
inadmissible basically flouting
the law of deliberately disregarding the
law
in what appears to be almost all of
their cases
across the board for a matter of years
at issue is compliance with section 490
the law that police must seek extension
orders
to hold evidence beyond 90 days in court
it was revealed that
i hit was warned as early as 2007
by crown and a justice of the peace not
to ignore that section
in a quitting guild the judge found the
blanket non-compliance policy
continued beyond 2014 when i hit
supposedly dumped the directive the i
hit
policy of non-compliance amounts to
systemic
flagrant disregard for charter protected
rights
said the judge i find that ihit was at
best
willfully blind towards the charter
implications of the policy
the fact that the police in this case
sought and received
legal advice that explicitly deemed
compliance mandatory
makes these actions more egregious we
reached out to all levels of the rcmp
including national headquarters in
ottawa to request an interview
but we did not get one in time for this
story in an email the acting boss of the
homicide team
said i can confirm that i hit his sense
taken steps
to ensure our investigative standards
and actions
align with and are compliant with
section 490.
she adds they're talking with bc's
prosecution service
on how to move forward these are not
guidelines
this is the law vancouver lawyer ravi
hira can't speak about the specifics of
this case
but he says newly uncovered information
could be a tool for the defense in
homicide convictions
still under appeal if an agency elects
deliberately elects not to engage
in that which is required by the law
in my opinion that investigative agency
is playing russian roulette with
evidence
jordan armstrong global news vancouver
coming up the florida lawmaker accused
of sex trafficking
involving a minor
republican representative matt gates is
the focus of two investigations
one by the fbi another by the house
ethics committee
gates is accused of sex trafficking
involving a teenager
a staunch supporter of donald trump he
denies the allegations
but tonight the calls for his
resignation are growing jennifer johnson
reports
florida congressman matt gates with his
fiancee making his first public
appearance
since the house ethics committee began
an investigation into whether he
violated sex trafficking laws
the smears against me range from
distortions of my personal life
to wild and i mean wild conspiracy
theories
i won't be intimidated by a lying media
gates taking a page from his close ally
former president donald trump's playbook
but it was trump's department of justice
that started the investigation
of gates and his alleged sexual
relationship with the 17 year old girl
categorical denials are all about a
political career right now
prosecutors don't pay a lot of attention
to that new allegations claim
gates sent money to an accused sex
trafficker joel greenberg
who then gave it to three young women in
2018
greenberg is expected to plead guilty to
federal crimes as part of an undisclosed
deal
i'm sure matt gates is not feeling very
comfortable today the house committee is
looking into a variety of violations
including that gates allegedly shared
inappropriate images or videos while in
house chambers
if in fact these allegations are true of
course being removed from the judiciary
committee
is the least that could be done gates a
once rising star among conservatives
denies all the allegations against him
jennifer johnson global news
washington still ahead brazil's
climbing death toll from cover 19 and
still the president downplays the virus
you're watching global national
[Music]
for the first time in this pandemic
brazil's daily death toll surpassed
4 000 people the country's president has
long
downplayed the risks of the virus
encouraging regions to avoid lockdown
but this is where the p1 variant was
first detected the one that's more
contagious
and has the potential to lower the
effectiveness of some vaccines
here's mike drillet in sao paulo brazil
a ghoulish scene is playing out for the
world to see
workers exhuming bodies from old
graveyards to make room for more
with no end to the misery in sight
brazilians have now put their faith in
the covid19 vaccines
which the government was late in
ordering and are in short supply
it gives us hope that there are better
days ahead says this community leader
the numbers tell a different story more
than 345
000 brazilians have died from covet 19.
second only to the united states
however brazil surpassed 4 000 deaths in
one day this past week
and experts now predict it will surpass
the us in total deaths
by july even as health officials raise
alarms about the dangers of the more
transmissible p1 variant
which has also appeared in canada little
is being done to slow its spread
it's a pity we've become an
embarrassment to the world says this
union leader
brazil is a time bomb and breeding
ground for the coronavirus
much of the blame is being heaped on
president jair bolsonaro
an ally of former u.s president donald
trump
bolsonaro has refused to take the
vaccine openly derided lockdowns and
masks
and told brazilians to stop whining
about the virus
this virus like others is here to stay
and will remain for a lifetime he said
it is practically impossible to
eradicate what are we going to do until
then
medicine and supplies to treat covet 19
are running dangerously low
if the health care system collapses as
doctors in overwhelmed hospitals warn
is possible they may not be able to do
much
microlight global news toronto
up next the lessons teachers need to
help racialize students
in the past year remote learning has
blurred the line between classrooms and
living rooms
it's given parents new insight into what
their kids are learning
and what lessons are lacking in toronto
a group of black fathers is calling for
change
as candice daniel explains what started
as a conversation
among friends has transformed into a
campaign for equity
in education it all started here
in a local park the dads have been
friends for years and have grown into a
support network
for each other what's up fellas how you
guys doing
going public on youtube well this is a
first
we came together today just to have a
quick conversation about
some of our feelings about about growing
up black and having our kids grow up
black
in east york and being part of the
education system
in march they decided to take action
when the pandemic gave them
new insights into what was being said in
their kids remote classes
first i want to preface that i'm a
teacher the teachers have my full
support
that being said i don't think that
there's proper
training for teachers to talk about race
so they made this video about their
experiences
and what they hoped to see in education
and they sent the video to their
children's principals
and vice principals inclusive language
inclusive literature and representation
those are three things that we said to
these principals these are things that
you can do this is low hanging fruit
funke specializes in the history of
canada's education system
there are people in our school boards
there are people who are working
in the ministry of education who are
deeply invested
in creating models and creating
important
language that educators need to use and
adapt and
take into the classroom but for some
reason there is this disconnect
part of the problem she says is there
isn't a standard level of training for
canadian teachers
it differs from province to province
there are educators in individual
classrooms that are thinking critically
about how to address and speak to their
black students and then there are
schools that aren't doing it well
and as a result we don't have a uniform
way of understanding whether or not
we're doing it right
at the time of our interview only one of
four schools had acknowledged receiving
the video
and the father's offer to help global
news contacted the schools
and since then all principals have
reached out to the respective dads
i don't know what the next step is but i
hope this can start a conversation a
deeper conversation about what are we
really doing
are we ticking boxes or are we really
doing something different
and that i don't have the answer to
candace daniel
global news for more on candace's
conversation with the fathers and the
change they hope to see
be sure to watch the new reality tonight
at 7 pm
on global and that is global national
for this saturday night
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
the port credit lighthouse
in mississauga we would love to see your
corner of the country so
please keep sending your photos thank
you for watching and i'll see you back
here tomorrow
have a great night